っと
金ちゃん弾みそうです
なっています
dare to
ああああああああ
ano 教
オゾンてるわー
アーサーあああうわあ
本日弾みそうですちょっとネイルのねほんと一体的にね俺も思ってるよ
だけどハースえーっ
hey
[音楽]
あああああ
ああうわあちょっと話を戻すと
今東京に言いますほら昨日からちょっとお仕事というように来てまして
でも今日も仕事に取り組んでいるんですけども東京の家に帰ろうと思って帰ったら東京
の家の鍵を忘れました
俺の意思だよ
ran
あーそれいいかしてオルガニスト全面的に謝るごめんなさい
だれよあああああああ誰やー
あーおれであの帰りますがなくて僕は bang 喫茶満喫に留まりましたそこで事件
は起きました
その前日もあんまり寝てなくてすごい出向くてればちょっと
ある撮影が終わったんですけどから餃子撮影大変そうだなと思ってちょっとちゃんとで
よって思って満喫に入ってや広いでコーナーだ
これでくらいに包んでグーッと探しに行ってそこで寝よって来たんですけどそしたら隣
の席のやろが
とんでもで万っては同等でもないから見れば分かると思いますどうぞ
うじゃ
は仏所奪えずとっえっ
いやいいよ百歩譲るよ100歩譲りますよキャップ受領あっ歩譲って僕が言いたいとは
あのまあ僕は不全と思ったんですね大イビキっていうのはもそのなんか寝てると思って
も出てるが6種でちゃうことなんて僕はもを心とことを超えないわけなんですよ
さあチェーンだってそうじゃ俺の隣の人が寝たんで悪気があったわけじゃないんですよ
は歴があっていびきをかく方と思ったわけじゃなくてもう寝ちゃって
だから無意識にあるの騒音が鳴り響いたわけですその満喫の中全体に
rar
成果にそうになる予想やもう手が出そうになるよ
さらに小うるさいドブロコンビのマンってなんか上に比べたのか犯せ
ちょっと dots けどちょっと作ってるんだよなぁ
そしてさらには
[音楽]
残土つだよ復旧打って何の音だよもううるさすぎて怒りでマニュアル内容が頭に入って
こなかったよ
そして早送りにしてみると
なんかゲームの洞窟の音楽みたいにあったよはいということが実は
漫喫でありましたいやもちろんもちろんですよ
鍵を忘れと僕のミスでもあるんですけどもいろんな人が使う場所で大きな音を断つだめ
だと込んでいてはでもなんかいびきをかいてたからわざとやってるわけじゃないわざと
白虎やってるわけじゃないから地下牢にもしっかり中
たんですよかといってそれをまだ満喫の定義さんどこにいってよじゃあのいびき
うるさいんですよって言うのもなんかぷがなんかすぐに気にするタイプの曲だなぁ
みたいな感じは思われるのも嫌ねどうすればよかったんですかああどうしようもでき
なかったんですけどもう結局後の結果もうん削除を歌ってイライラしイライラしてもう
当初はなくて
[音楽]
見ることをやめました
me
re いっ
大
を
グッ